The first onigirazu I'm going to prepare is tuna mayonnaise.
Start by putting one whole can of tuna into a bowl.
This will give you around two servings.
Season with salt and black pepper.
Add a generous amount of mayonnaise, some lemon juice...
...and around three tablespoons of finely-chopped onions.
Give it a good mix.
The principles behind all of the onigirazu will be the same.
Start by placing a sheet of cling film onto a chopping board.
Take one roasted nori seaweed sheet.
They will usually have one side which has a rougher texture...
...and the other side with a shinier and smoother texture.
When making sushi rolls or onigirazu, ensure that the rough side is facing up.
This is so that the smoother, aesthetically pleasing side...
...is visible on the  outside of the onigirazu.
Place some warm steamed rice in the center of the nori sheet,...
...season with salt, place some lettuce...
...and cucumber on top of the rice,...
...followed by the tuna mayonnaise.
Then, top off with some more rice.
Season again with some salt.
Next, fold in the edges to create a parcel.
It's important not to squeeze too hard...
...as you'll end up with a really dense and unpleasant texture when eating.
Finally, wrap the onigirazu with the cling film.
Reshape and allow to rest on the side for a few minutes,...
...enough time for the edges of the nori to stick together to form a parcel.